c'est un enjeu industriel de premier
plan et c'est aussi vous l'avez sans
doute constaté l'équipement électronique
en vogue chez les adolescents en
particulier les mp3 ces petits baladeurs
numériques qui permettent de télécharger
des disques d'écouter de la musique en
toute circonstance devienne l'objet
d'une féroce bataille microsoft se lance
sur le marché pour concurrencer apple et
son i pod ivan martin est clos et le
compte
bien calé dans les oreilles
leurs accessoires fétiches
[Musique]
un lecteur mp3 tout petit mais suffisant
pour trimballer des milliers de morceaux
avec soin
c'est plus agréable que danton le métro
vous l'emporter partout avec vous ah oui
la boutique dans les transports parfois
pas porter chez fameux cds
un lecteur cd ses imposantes au même
moment à quelques milliers de kilomètres
de là big eight s'en frotte les mains
autant de clients potentiels pour son
tout nouveau baladeur numérique le zune
les unes c'est un tout nouveau produit
pour microsoft nous en avons 1 aussi
maintenant il a un grand écran et une
connexion sans fil
le zune la nouvelle arme de microsoft
lancé pour détrôner l'ipod le mp3 de son
grand rival apple déjà vendu à 67
millions d'exemplaires depuis cinq ans
pour ça c'est le ipod nano donc là on
met de la musique et de la faute au
dessus ça c'est un autre besser ça c'est
notre but c'est quand vous vendez 10 mp3
vous en demandez combien de cette marque
du seul des trois enfants après cet
appareil de cette marque prix moyen de
ces petits joujoux 250 euros mais pour
ce tarif cet avis you nadeau s'est
offert bien plus qu'un simple baladeur
ça me permet d'écouter de la musique
devant des photos je le branche
directement sur ma voiture
je vais même des jeux et je le pense
carrément sur ma télé si je le désire
comme ça je défie les unes ne sera pas
commercialisée en europe avant plusieurs
mois apple peut encore dormir sur ses
deux oreilles
[Musique]